foreign
of the habitable landscape is now
converted over to farmland and 70 of
that is basically for for cattle or for
the feed to feed cattle so any 30 for
cereal crops now as a as a scientist I
can tell you that between the grass and
the cow 90 of the energy is lost so that
is not an efficient way of farming not
in no way whatsoever it's a very very
inefficient way of farming and in the UK
73 of the land is now given over to
agriculture I defy you to take me
anywhere in the UK landscape and show me
a natural a natural landscape and if you
think going to the lake District or
North Wales is a natural landscape no it
isn't it's been completely deforested it
is completely degraded and I do agree
with Natalie on this point our landscape
is very very severely depleted I mean it
kind of begs the question doesn't it so
you say this and you know it's a very
human reaction to say gosh that's
terrible what can we do about it but I
feel like the implication in what you're
suggesting is that we should go kind of
go back right how to rewind effectively
to to undo all these kinds of things but
I mean is is that what you're saying and
also does that involve us or having to
go back to farming and feudal life or
how how does this look no what we do is
we take lots of the knowledge that we've
lost and and and we've forgotten and
combine it with our modern
understandings so a great example of
this is um there's a book called
miraculous abundance which is written by
the farmers
um in farm back Elohim in Normandy in
France and they take a thousand square
meters of land and that produces from
one person's labor fruit and vegetables
enough to produce a rural French income
of 22 000 Euros a year which is a very
good rule of French income it produces
huge quantity piece of fresh fruits and
vegetables it works on permaculture and
agroecological principles is organic and
so what it does is it uses knowledge a
lot of this knowledge was actually comes
from historically the market gardeners
around Paris 100 years ago used to
produce do things like use they had a
lot of
manure from horses then they produced
tomatoes in March and April in Paris by
using that heat this is all Knowledge
and Skills and what we need is far more
science far more understanding we're now
coming to Farmers 100 years ago
understood that you had to look after
the soil there was a 1930s Italian
proverb that said artificial fertilizer
is good for the father and bad for the
Sun they understood that applying that
fertilizer was trashing the soil we we
lost that knowledge we recovered that
knowledge we combine it with our
understanding now far more understanding
about soil science about human
microbiomes this is the kind of Science
and understanding agroecology
permaculture we need new understandings
new things but this is the science the
kind of science we need I mean maybe I'm
surrounded by experts in farming neither
of whom I think far
Farmers would probably use a more
efficient system if it was available as
nationally tells them or it must tells
them but it isn't it's actually I am a
small farmer in this mobile I have a
small farm in France with 12 lambs and
six sheep and 18 geese and 40 chickens
on it and it's wonderfully eco-friendly
you'd be but it's incredibly inefficient
and uh yeah I think if we gave you a 100
Acre Farm you would be bankrupt within
six months uh I think Mark would be
bankrupt in three years I would be
bankrupt in about two months Farmers
know quite a lot about farming don't
trust armchair Farmers to tell you how
to run the agricultural industry of this
country the echo enthusia what was his
name the chap who wrote a crash of 75
who said that the world was going to run
out of food by 1975 there'd be 10
billion 10 million dead by that time and
so on they eventually made him a member
of the Royal Society it was nonsense
the advances in agriculture have enabled
us to feed 8 billion people with less
land than we were feeding 6 billion
people
I mean I'm also struck by the fact that
none of you have disagreed with the use
of science to optimize effectively again
I should disclaimer for those of you in
the audience I'm a molecular biologist
I'm a scientist as well so I like to
hear things like optimization wherever I
go but um you know it sounds like you're
all on board with the using of tech
technology and science to improve the
efficiency of the system is that is that
at least a Common Thread that we can
find between us I think the question is
what kind of Science and what we've
relied on over the past few decades has
dominated our science as an extremely
reductive model that's looked for silver
bullets that said oh
um
the plants we want to get more yields
we'll throw some more nitrogen
fertilizer on and that'll get more yield
without thinking about what will that do
to the soil microbes what will that do
to the long-term security structure of
the soil all of those things have been
short-term and I would say you know the
farmers now the leading Farmers now I
visited a farmer over um in Shropshire
um Maize farmer Maize corn a huge
problem in terms of damage to soil
structure and he was doing lots of
different experiments with with under
crops with planting various legumes to
protect the soil and look after but you
know we keep coming back to capitalism
because he said to me
this seed the veg costs 20 pounds a kilo
for seed this costs 15 pounds a kilo
this costs 12 pounds a kilo
and the supermarket won't pay me enough
for my maze or or the um the cattle feed
per Merchant won't pay me enough from a
maze to actually do that so we have a
system where Farmers have been forced
into more and more production and in
this country in particular we've
destroyed all of the government
independent Agricultural Extension so
it's all come from the seed companies
the fertilizer companies that's where
the information to Farmers has come from
and it's wrecked our land and if you go
to the Oxford farming conference you
will hear more and more mainstream
General Farmers saying we have to change
the nfu and the soil Association are
getting closer and closer every year
was Splendid I mean if if your arguments
and your evidence and your science Works
uh I'm sure scientists as farmers will
lack it lap it up they want to do things
that are more efficient not less
efficient things that will give them
yield without destroying their soil
rather than things which won't give them
a yield and will destroy their soil they
are not stupid Farmers the idea however
that people who know nothing about
farming like this panel here except for
me in a small way I know how to lose
money in a small farm uh should should
dictate just don't believe it look at
what happened in the Soviet Union when
politicians took over farming the Bread
Basket of the world was turned into a
huge importer of food
Ukraine the great massive famines took
place so just please don't for a moment
give any Credence to armchair Farmers so
if I could come into this at this point
I honestly do not want to dictate to any
of you what you do in your Lifestyles
but if we carry on as we are at present
then you know that this is going to be
catastrophic in a few Generations
um I I think there's there are ways to
bind back and I think we started on this
this conversation with with winding back
and also then we we talked about
technology so so technology can be part
of the solution but technology is not
going to save you you're often peddled
ideas on the media that technology is
going to come along and be your great
salvation so you might all decide to go
and drive electric cars for example and
that will certainly help in the near
term in terms of the carbon emissions to
the atmosphere but it won't help in the
long term because the same embedded
problems are there so technology is part
of the solution but you and I have to
change our Behavior so I support Farmers
I'm not against farmers in any way
whatsoever but if I reel off the
statistics to you again since the 1960s
meat production meat consumption on
planet Earth has doubled it's it's go
it's it's not wonderful because of the
the loss of energy between grass and cow
it's a 90 loss and the amount of energy
coming in it's a lot of energy but the
grass also struggles to fix it as well
so that's not sustainable in the long
term and I will just add to that if we
carry on if we all decide we want a meat
Rich diet like Argentina or Australia or
or North America then you can kiss
goodbye to all of the forests on this
planet and you can kiss goodbye to the
wildlife too but if you change your
behavior if you eat less meat you can
make a big difference and you can allow
large areas of the planet to become
reforested stabilizing the climate
climate stabilizing those ecosystems you
really can make a difference but it also
involves behavioral change it's not just
technology
oh
my God
Mark and I are agreeing on lots of
things but I also want to stress that
what we need is system change not
climate change and it's all very well to
say to people
um you know we can't have anything like
one for one replacement between fossil
fuel cars and electric cars
but unless you make walking and safety
cycling safe and convenient unless you
provide buses into rural areas unless
you give people an alternative that
doesn't mean the train costs 10 times as
much as it would to drive a car
then people just are not available to
people we have to make the
environmentally sensitive socially
responsible thing to do the easiest
cheapest and simplest thing to do so
people don't have to choose that's just
naturally what you do and that's what
system change means kind of I mean I
kind of want to go back to to the sort
of original question here though which
is this idea that if we actually rewind
back to this sort of other form of
Agriculture or the sort of historic way
of doing things that somehow we would
end up escaping the current woes that we
have in terms of status hierarchy and
oppression of the modern civilization
explicitly and I feel like that's kind
of a big claim isn't it to suggest that
the the entire Bedrock of our society
and framework of seeing the world is
down to how we Farm our food and I'm I'm
obviously not an expert in this but I'm
I'm curious as to whether or not we
think that if we did make changes like
that we would actually see this radical
shift in the entire fabric of our
society or not
well I'll start on that to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV